welcome back to new rockstars I'm Erik
Bosse and with spider-man back in the
MCU it makes his most recent installment
is confusing trust shattering battle
with Mysterio all the more important to
re-examine from every angle because
however you interpret Quentin Beck's
fate Mysterio in some form remains alive
at the end of the film either as a team
Mysterio of ex Stark Industries
engineers continuing to distribute fake
news to undermine Peter Parker at every
turn or and actually not dead Quentin
Beck that Peter stupidly used the
biggest words to check the pulse of this
trio all illusions are down Peter real
real can mean anything to a literalist
AI like Edith this still alive criminal
pretending to be dead is real
technically okay cool MJ let's kiss now
that part from home is out on blu-ray
the effects artists behind the film have
opened up on the creative processes
behind the film's most elaborate
sequence the Mysterio illusion battle
and the reason I love this is the
characters on Team Mysterio are
themselves visual storytellers VFX
artists and filmmakers just as the real
VFX artists of this movie had to
illustrate concept art and render 3d
imagery to WoW and deceive us so did the
artists within the movie Beck cooter
Mandriva Janice Victoria the others -
Wow in deceit Peter and the people in
his world I am gonna break down frame by
frame
all of Mysterio's illusions to break
down some of the fascinating details
that you still might not have seen join
me as I go inside marvel
[Music]
now the first thing I should point out
is that mysterio is so mysterious that
we still do not know his name now
Quentin Beck is the name that Jake
Gyllenhaal's character goes by
throughout the film and this this mr.
Beck you can call me Quentin but he
hints later in his victory speech that
that might not be his actual name the
story you created of a soldier from
another earth named Quentin fighting
space sponsors in Europe is totally
ridiculous and apparently exactly the
kind of thing people will believe right
now I mean everybody a soldier from
another earth named Quinton he's making
it sound like everything about his
identity that we were told being from
another dimension his dead family being
named Quinton was all fiction conceived
by Goethe man and it would make sense
for Quinton back to be a pseudonym as a
former employee of Tony Stark the
engineer who invented barf he said that
stark fired him for being unstable
assuming that's true he would have to at
least change his name to get anywhere
close to Nick Fury Maria hill or Peter
Parker even if they told Furion Hill
that he was from another dimension
they've likely run some kind of
background check on his name and if he
came up as a former Stark Industries
employee who was fired for being
unstable he would immediately be red
flagged for classic supervillain origin
so Gyllenhaal's character's name was
most likely totally different when he
was still working under Stark even
though they call him Quentin Beck that
name is a lie it reaches its climax in
Berlin where Mysterio turns on Peter in
the darkest way possible we know from
the end of the sequence that Nick Fury
the whole time is a projection Overbeck
animo cap suit and yet again his name's
probably not back just you know self
project quotation marks around Beck
every time I say his name anyway driving
the car that picked up Peter at the
Berlin trade station was not Nick Fury
its Beck the way the window slides down
to reveal Fury's face is the same way
that Barth projections trickle down to
reveal the truth underneath the team
must have projected Sam Jackson's face
and voice so that inches away from him
Peter Parker would not be able to tell
the difference which is insane graphics
display or you know my theory that
everyone in the MCU was born with like a
vision defect that causes them to see
things like animated
rhinos as perfectly normal anyway that
smokescreen also applies to the Europe
all exterior and interior as they arrive
now the VFX artist explained that they
had to construct three layers of
settings throughout which to choreograph
Peter and Becks movement the base
reality of the construction site the
false layer of Europe all in the
illusion layer of Peters nightmare
imagery and that each of these layers
had to be linked to the geography would
stay consistent team Mysterio in the
movie had to do the same thing they to
choreograph all of this so imagine them
in their workshop space thinking okay
BEC s fury will lead Peter up these
steps and then our drones will project
Europe all surfaces here and here and
here and here and here and then he's
gonna be able to walk four steps to this
ledge yeah these folks had to have been
obsessive there's no way people like
this are gonna be over and done with in
just one movie now in this big
theatrical presentation they also
project Maria Hill notice that after
Hill asks Peter about Edith once Peter
tosses over the drone piece and reveals
that he has figured out Beck's entire
masquerade she runs out of reactions she
falls silent and just kind of rubs her
face as she turns to the window
presumably those reactions would have
been pre-recorded and pre-rendered
before Peter even arrived at the spot
and once he revealed what he knew team
Mysterio might not have had a response
ready to go from he'll now shortly after
this when the hill projection fades away
along with rest of the room Beck
cleverly reacts to it as fury would and
he makes Peter think fury has been shot
and killed by the drum so within this
grander illusion team Mysterio tricks
Peter with an inner Yuri illusion so
that later the sight of fury will come
to Peter as a form of relief lowering
Peters already rattled inhibitions to
get him to spill the info that they were
always after how much Peter knows and
who else knows it so by presetting this
Easton hole a fake fury his big death
big resurrection that was the secret key
to this whole psychological torture the
rest was just set dressing but it's also
fascinated to see the creativity that
went into that set dressing because it
was all uniquely tailored to
psychologically torture the teenage
Peter Parker it begins by projecting him
inside the Hall of his high school but
he's wearing his red in blue Spidey suit
now not the black night monkey one that
he was given all this taps into Peters
anxiety a balancing highschool life with
his superhero
and it's difficulty keeping those worlds
separate you notice the high school is
shaded to be a horror film green mist
doors to classrooms and lockers just
abandoned open dangling flickering
lights it's kind of like a
post-apocalyptic zombie film which as
we'll see later in a solution it becomes
that literally Peters actual
surroundings in this moment is the
construction site like when he spends
around the geography of the concrete
piling remains fixed so that when he
punches where he thinks Mysterio is and
have you tracked while the camera
movement that column would have been
there from the beginning
now the VFX artists from frame store the
company that created the sequence
decided inspiration from The Truman Show
in this moment when Truman's sailboat
moves into what he thinks is the open
landscape it crashes into the wall
because it's a false illusion designed
to control him next mysterious illusion
transports Peter to the observation deck
of the Eiffel Tower the place of Peter
had told back previously that he wanted
to confess his love to MJ the full moon
becomes Mysterio's helmet
the edge that Peter dives over to save
MJ is the actual edge of the
construction site level but he doesn't
have the full height of the Eiffel Tower
from which to swing to safety and like
diving into the shallow end of a
swimming pool Peter hits the
construction-site floor that's just one
floor below and then Peter as if on a
bullet train remember that's gonna
import later he zips over to this Queens
city block which Mysterio's giant fist
punches through displaying Mysterio as
giant size is an image taken from the
spider-man comics but it's also another
scare tactic designed to hit very close
to home with the team Mysterio saying
that their warpath can move on from
European cities to Peter's home
community in Queens New York now in
reality what knocked Peter off the
construction site was likely an element
introduced in the Hulk movies no not
Hulk himself though we'll never know for
sure
no on Tower Bridge later the drones hit
Peter with this sonic shockwave director
said that it was the same tech used on
Hulk in his first movie so Peter falls a
few floors to the ground below and he
falls through this interesting webbing
patterns the design looking very similar
to some of the trippy spider-verse
imagery from into the spider verse as if
Peter is tumbling through a rabbit hole
not knowing what reality he'll end up in
the drones follow him down and transform
into these mirror shards that box in
Peter now the VFX artist said that they
borrowed some these visuals from the
Matrix films spider-man reaches out to
touch the mirror and he gets cloned too
kind of like how neo does in the first
matrix and then all of us might have
made duplicates
about in dog pile on him just like how
the agent smith copies dog piled on neo
and the Matrix Reloaded next Peter finds
himself in his original sweat suit
spider-man costume from before being
recruited by Stark into the Avengers
when he was still a grounded loser who
doesn't belong in this picture making
him feel increasingly isolated in this
moment the massive statues crumbled
around him are actually before Avengers
who died or retired during the infinity
war in game conflict the ones shown in
far from homes opening tribute montage
the faces of cap and Iron Man are
crumbled on the ground beside Peter
Black Widow and vision are still
standing Stark's head is on the ground
while his body remains standing with his
gauntlet outstretched and an overhead
shot shows Peter standing on a star of
cap shield evoking his entrance into the
MCU in civil war snatching that shield
and over all of this the largest statue
is that of Mysterio posing as the
world's new Avenger looming over the
ashes of the old generation again
Mysterio as using Peters true
surroundings against him luring Peter to
web down what's actually a construction
crane on top of him and then when the
dust settles Peter finds himself at Tony
Stark's grave really rubbing in the
survivor's guilt after Tony's death and
in-game the original plan for this
visual was to depict Tony's face as a
bear skull under the helmet the camera
would zoom in on inspired by the opening
title imagery the double-oh-seven
Spectre film the artists also sided the
Evil Dead films as an influence but
really the way the zombie Iron Man
crawls toward Peter was actually
inspired by the look of the a Tron
drones in Avengers age of Ultron when
the broken robots in the final act had
pieces hanging off them as they dragged
their parts around and then Peter is
trapped inside a snow globe of New York
City the pile of snow is actually a pile
of gravel in the construction site but
the skyscrapers include the Avengers
Tower and it all fills with his Green
Smoke as Peter tries to tuck away from
it as if he's suffocating inside this
fishbowl and the look of this orb helmet
was inspired by the prophecy orbs of the
Ministry of Magic and the final act of
Harry Potter in the order of the Phoenix
with the idea being that it would become
a rolling Boulder chasing Peter like the
boulder and Raiders of the Lost Ark but
then Beck delivers his master stroke he
fakes his own death via fake death fury
saving Peter from the threat that he
also created making Peter comfortable
enough to share who else from his friend
group knows the truth about that but
then twists upon twists upon twists
Peter realizes he is still in the
illusion and then all the nightmares
crashed down on Peter once more as his
world collapses around him and the last
blow is also one that Peter doesn't see
coming a freaking bullet train a visual
that Peter had just been primed to see
as an illusion this failure by Peter
foreshadowed the rock-bottom state that
he'll find himself in at the end of the
film and the movie's post-credits scene
his private life and public persona
crashed on top of each other he feels
unsafe in his own neighborhood his
relationship with MJ is now threatened
in the world now sees Mysterio as a
worthy successor to iron man's legacy
not spider-man in all this news hit
submit' once like a speeding train but
even more importantly Quentin Beck's
masterstroke of using a fake fury and
his own fake death to lure Peter into a
state of comfort while Beck still alive
pulls a rug out from under him that
might also foreshadow what's really
going on in this final moment because
Beck if that is even his name probably
not appears to die but that death
actually could be another deception to
allow him to continue his main narrative
as supposed Beck put in his supposed
final words what role do you think team
Mysterio could play in future spider-man
films comment down below with your
thoughts and if you plan to attend Los
Angeles Comic Con this weekend I in the
other hosts of new rock stars will be
hosting a panel on Saturday October 12th
at 3:00 p.m. if you're gonna be around
we would love to see you there and field
all of your questions about things that
we normally wouldn't talk about follow
me on instagram and twitter at EA vas
and subscribe to new rock stars who join
us as we go deeper in deeper inside
Marvel thank you for joining me and
honestly all Peter had to ask Edith was
finished it himself because either Beck
would for sure be dead or her that's
some real commitment
[Music]